Hey how's it going my name's Booker and
in this video I'm going to show you how
to build a group chat similar to slide
using react Jas and chat heads which is
a developer tool and my team and I a
building hair pusher in the end will
have an app where users can send and
receive messages see who's typing with
Nikki typing indicators and to top it to
a lot a real time who's on line where's
the app we're going to build is going to
resemble and it could well be used
for team communication but I realized
having built the project and recorded
the video yesterday but the concepts and
techniques we're going to look at could
be used for most types of chats
applications be that customer messaging
app maybe for a CRM maybe a group chat
for your community or even in-game chat
if you're a game developer I wanted to
quickly mention that all the code is on
github the link is in the description my
even took the liberty of writing up a
step-by-step tutorial based on the exact
same code you're going to see in this
video so if you want to follow along you
can maybe watch the video and reference
new code on github it's up to you if at
any point you find yourself enjoying the
video please drop a like on the YouTube
video you can also follow me on Twitter
I'm at work encouraged but yeah I'm
excited let's die then
instead of starting from complete
scratch we're going to download a
starter template I created earlier we'll
have a poke around the code in just a
second to see exactly what's happening
the first off download this repository
which you can do by coming here and
clicking on download zip or by copying
the link and having to be terminal but
we can run a git clone followed by the
link to the repository followed by the
name of the local folder you want to
download that code into if we navigate
into that folder we can run npm install
to bring in those local dependencies
pretty standard stuff if we open the
project up we can see where there aren't
really that many files in this public
folder we have an index.html file this
mainly exists just to give us something
to mount our react application on to we
won't be touching this HTML file going
forward instead of source we have some
basic react application files including
an empty components directory where
we'll be creating some of our components
as we go forward the real meats here is
this app dot J's file which will add
more code to as we go forward but right
now just renders a simple component with
the text slack if we look at package
JSON you can see that we're using react
scripts to run the react application and
we also have a star script where we can
run both the server which I'll show you
in a second as well as the clients all
with one command the server is actually
the main reason this templates exists I
didn't want to spend too much time
explaining how to set up a simple
Express server because if you already
know expressed this hair is going to
look super familiar to you it doesn't
need explaining if you don't know
Express very well which is totally ok
then it doesn't really matter too much
we're not going to spend very much time
on the server now the first thing we're
going to want to do when the user loads
our application is ask them what is your
username will use this username to
create a CH hug hit user to capture
about username we're going to create a
username form component and we're going
to create that component instead of the
components directory
I just show
first we'll import react van will create
our username form components inside the
username form we'll create a constructor
that takes some props and will
immediately pass those props to the
super function we'll also set some
initial state for our application next
we'll create a render function will
return a simple form whenever this input
here is updated what changed
we're going to call this unchanged and
then whenever the form is submitted
we're going to call based on submit
we'll also need to go back up to the
constructor and bind both of those
functions to Bess
nice so this is a pretty standard react
form what we're doing is we're creating
a controlled components
bus that whenever the user enters some
inputs we updates our components stains
whenever the form is submitted we take
back component States here and we pass
it through the on submit prop which we
expect
whoever's referencing this form to pass
in fact less reference this form now
just to make sure everything is in order
so we'll go to app Doge is and imports
user name form from components slash
user name form and then instead of
returning just protects like let's
return the user name form specify that
on submit problem we'll just say when we
gather user name let's alert it just to
make sure things are in order so then
now if I create a new splits and run the
application using NPM run starts or
actually we can just do NPM start for
short if I should spin up a server so
that we can go to localhost 3000 and to
a user name like Booker and when we hit
some meds we can catch about username
and show it in an alert but actually we
don't want to just show it in analog in
and alert whenever this user enters
their username we want to send that to
our server application and create H hat
kid user but before we can do that we
must first create a chat kids
application or a check it instance so
had to push it up on slash check here
and click sign up you'll have to create
a new account I already have one so I'll
log in to an existing account real quick
once you have a dashboard and the chat
kit click create new and creates a new
check it instance I'm going to call mine
slack clone the weight check it works
essentially is that you install H
hotcake Client SDK there as the case for
JavaScript Swift and Android will be
using javascript and then you can
subscribe to a room where you'll receive
an event every time a new messages sands
on the same client you can also send
message
you can send plain text or you can send
files so you can send video messages or
your messages whatever you like once you
have this kind of fundamental chat in
place it becomes quite easy to add
things like typing indicators and online
user presence which I'll show you how to
do later in this video right now I just
want you to take notes of the keys tab
in the dashboard where you can see your
instance locator and secret key we'll
need these in just a second
now most interactions in chat care they
happen on the clients like I just showed
you their client SDKs the Java Script
Swift and Android and you can even use
these libraries together so you could
build a web application as well as the
Android application and they can both
communicate using chalk here which is
kind of cool but if you head to the dogs
you can see they're both clients SDKs
and server SDKs most interactions with
chat care happen on the clients that's
the same most code build rights will use
the client SDKs but will also need to
use the nodejs server SDK to create and
manage users so what I'll do is a copy
business relation command head to the
terminal and install pusher jacket
server now we have that SDK installed we
can open up server Jas and import jacket
from pusher - check it - server and then
we can create our own local jacket
instance by calling new jacket defaults
and we pass the VA's constructor
function firstly our instance locator
and secondly our secret key both of
which we can access from the dashboard
so let's copy by instance locator and
paste it in and then let's copy about
secret key and paste it in like so now
the main purpose behind this server is
to accept a post request from the
clients with the users username when we
receive that username we want to create
a chat kit user with that username we
have to do this on the client because it
needs to happen securely you can only
create a user
if you have this secret key and in order
for it to be secrets it has to remain on
the server so what we'll do is we'll
come down here and creates a new routes
handler called users that takes a post
request and as soon as that endpoint get
heads we're going to bring out the
username from the request body once we
have that username we're going to call
chat hit the create user specify the
users name to be username and we're also
going to specify their ID to be equal to
the username when that function is
finished executing we're going to send a
status of to a wants of the clients to
indicate that the user has been created
successfully it's possible that an error
will occur and in this particular case
it's particularly possible that the user
enters a username that already exists a
username which is already in use by
another chat kit user for this
particular jacket instance in that case
we're going to get a specific area and
and for our application bus actually
okay we don't mind if somebody answers a
username but already exists because
we're going to assume they're kind of
revisiting the application so what we're
going to do is we're going to check the
area type and check that this equal to
services slash jacket slash user slash
user underscore already underscore
exists and if the user already exists
we're going to send a status of 200 it's
indicate that the request was so
successful otherwise we're going to send
a status equal to the arrow status code
we're going to really love and check it
to our client I'm also going to pass
down the error jason just in case we
need to do to do some debugging later
down the line let's test this out real
quick let's create a new split and run
the server
and then in another split I'm going to
run curl specified that we want to send
a JSON request a post request and we'll
specify here the username to be equal to
VU and we want to send this post request
to hate to pay localhost 3001 slash
users and we should see when we run this
but the user is creative and indeed the
user is created now imagine that the
user just answered bat username on the
forum and they created their account but
maybe they closed what's have and they
came back later they're going to enter
the same username we don't need to
create Lee use it because it already
exists but we don't expect an error so
if we run this command now we shouldn't
be seeing an error but we are let's
debug this real quick we can see that
the arrow type is equal to services /
Chad care / user already exists now what
I tried to do earlier is make sure that
if the arab was equal to that that we
didn't actually relay the error and i
think what i've done is actually
mistyped the arrow type so let's save
that real quick restart the server and
then we'll try this again this time with
a different username just to make sure
in fact actually we can use the news
name through again if we run this we
should see that we get an ok response
you'll notice that when we created the
user for the first time it said created
when we kind of real aughh in we just
see okay as successful but we have some
indication that the user wasn't created
the request was successful next we can
go back to a pas and instead of just
alerting the username like we do here we
can send it to the server by our post
request first let's create a function to
handle the submission
and then update the on submit prop we'll
also need to create a constructor and
make sure to bind this stop on user name
submitted to this when the form is
submitted we're going to use the fetch
function to send a post request to
localhost for 3001 slash users batch
takes a second argument which lets us
specify the request method we'll be
sending a post request as well as any
headers and of course the body of the
request which is going to be the
username when this functions finished
executing we're going to get the
response for now we'll just write the
console success if an error happens
we'll consult our error the error we
also need to call super in the
constructor and then if we run the
server and we should see if we return to
the application reload the page and open
the developer tools but under the
network tab when we submit a username
like bar a post request is sent to the
server and we get like a status code of
201 created imagine the user closes the
tab and comes back and tries to answer
their username began we should see this
time that we get 200 ok so this is the
exact same result we saw in the terminal
earlier but now we've seen in the
browser which is one step closer to
completing our application you know
right now when the user submits their
username nothing visibly happens really
when they send their username after we
send that post request successfully we
want to transition them to a different
screen we want to show them the chat
application so let's create a never
contain a component for that chat screen
right now we're going to create it in
the source directory and it's going to
be called chow screen
jas this is going to be a component like
the ones you've defined before so let's
import react and then creates a simple
component within a pas we'll want to
import a Chow screen and then in the
constructor we're going to set some
initial States we're going to set a
current screen property and by default
that's going to be equal to what is your
user name screen while we're here we're
also going to create another property
for the current user name basically when
the request has been successfully sent
we're going to want to come here and set
a current user name equal to the user
name submitted by the user we need to
store it in our application stage so we
can pass it to the child screen
component in just a second we're also
going to want to say that once the form
has been successfully submitted we're
going to update the current screen to be
the Chow screen that way if we come down
here to the random method we can say it
this dot state dots current screen is
equal to what is your user name screen
then we're going to return the user name
form otherwise if this thought state or
current screen is equal to the chat
screen we're going to return the chat
screen and we're going to pass down the
current username which will be equal to
this the state dog current user name if
I run the application oh and excuse me
I've made a typo here
we can answer a user name like Bob and
when we hit some meds
we'll see that after the request has
been sent we get rendered B chat screen
in fact what we can do which is kind of
cool is go to the chat screen component
and we can access this top prop Stockard
user name and we can say something like
hello current user name so that now if I
sign in is like Booker and hit submit
you can see this hello Booker moving on
we're going to need to install the
jacket Client SDK and then imported
inside about chat screen component
within component dead mounts
we're going to create a new chat manager
just like when we instantiate a jacket
on the server we have to specify our
instance locator which again we can
access from the jacket dashboard we also
need to specify the user ID which is
going to be equal to this of the Provost
or current username just like we
reference down here we'll also need to
provide a chat kiss hoping provider and
we're going to specify the URL to be
HTTP localhost we thousand of one slash
or fancy codes now as you can probably
discern this is pointing to the server
we've been working on earlier but we
haven't created this authenticate routes
I'm going to do this really quick but
I'm actually going to paste it from my
clipboard as I'm not going to explain in
too much detail if you're following
along copy this code exactly well fancy
keishon is basically the act of proving
a user is who he or she says she is and
the real application on your server you
would typically have some logic to kind
of verify that the user is who he or she
says she is in our case we're just going
to assume everybody is who they say they
are and return a jacket token no matter
what the check it's hoping is returned
by this authenticate function but that's
all we really need to understand right
now let's save that and go back to our
chart screen here now we have our chat
manager
we can call chat manager dot connect so
you can net to check it once we've
connected we should get back the current
checker user which right now I'm just
going to print to the console if
something goes wrong which isn't likely
in this case I'll write the error to the
console just so we can do some debugging
let's run this now to see what happens
what we should see is that when we
reload the application and open the
developer tools if I connect as Booker
head submits we actually do get an error
we get a status code of 401 user ID
mismatch once if something goes wrong
which isn't likely in this case it is
unlikely in this case it is unlikely in
this case hmm I think was likely here is
that we have a problem with the
Authenticator endpoint which is ironic
because I copy and pasted it I think
what we need to do actually is specify a
user ID property here and not pass an
additional argument I save that and
quickly restart the server hopefully now
we'll see when we reload the page and
try and create an account and connect a
check here that we get the current user
awesome you can poke around here and
kind of get a look at the stuff
available to you when you're using chat
ket but a basic idea now is that now we
have this current user we can start to
perform actions in our chat what we'll
do firstly actually is head to the
dashboard and to the inspector tab the
inspector is a simple tool to help you
kind of do basic development and basic
testing which I care what we're going to
do is we're going to create a room to
create a room we firstly have to create
a user it doesn't really matter we're
not going to actually use by user and
then we're going to create a room called
general when we create the room we're
going to see the room ID which we should
copy or at least keep open in this tab
so we can reference it afterwards I'm
using the inspector to create a room for
this tutorial just to keep things simple
but realistically you are likely to
create your room
programmatically if you look at the dogs
for the node SDK or even the client-side
JavaScript SDK there are functions you
can call to create rooms I just want to
keep things simple so I'm using the
dashboard right here now in a second
we're going to make it so that we can
subscribe to messages that are sent in
that room the first time come to
creating new components in the
components directory called message list
or Jas and this is going to be the
component responsible for rendering a
list of messages for a particular
conversation or room the basic idea here
is the in the render function room to
return a container and then we're going
to take a messages prop that we expect
whoever's referencing this component to
passed down and we're going to map each
message
- a list item elements actually let's
make this a ul instead of a dev alright
now I'm gonna go back to chat screen and
I'm going to create a constructor for
this component
well I'll set some initial States in
particular once you create a messages
property then once you've successfully
connected to check here rather than just
print out the current user we're
actually going to write current user
does subscribe to room will specify the
room ID to be the room ID that we copied
just a second ago from the dashboard
will specify the message limits to be
100 and I'll explain this property a bit
more in a second and then we're going to
create a hooks property
excuse me hooks not books where when a
new message is received we're going to
call this course add States
and we're going to take that new message
and we're going to essentially add it to
the existing messages array I'm going to
quickly make sure that I return the
promise returned by subscribe to room so
that down here I can call van an access
to current room we'll need to listen
just a little bit most likely next what
I'm going to do is go down to the render
function and I'm going to render the
message list if I listen pause a real
quick from components slash a message
list and then down here I can reference
the message list and say the messages
are equals of this those state Dom
messages now what we should see if we
save this file and run the application
is that after I reference super which I
always forget for some reason we should
be able to go to the app reload the page
create a new user or sign in with an
existing user and then from a vendor
each hat kid dashboard we can actually
send some task messages so if I send the
text hello right here and go back to
this tab you can see that the user
called chuckette dashboard has written
the text hello in fact if I open up
these windows side by side you can see
that as I type messages and hit save
this interface is updated in real time
the next step is to enable the user to
answer the message rather than using the
dashboard this inspectors handy just as
a kind of sanity check we want to make
sure that we're subscribing to messages
successfully so we can send a test
message and make sure it registers the
formatting is a bit weird but we'll fix
that in just a little bit let's give our
user a way to send a message before they
can send a message we need to kind of
capture the tax which we'll do using a
forum so let's create a new component in
the components folder called sand
message form Dodge is
and actually this is going to be
incredibly similar to the username form
we defined earlier so to save some time
I'm actually going to open up about
using the in form copy the contents
paste this into the send message board
and then just do a bit of refactoring if
I then go to app or sorry chat screen je
s I can import resend message form and
then at the bottom here in the render
function I can render that send message
born and we'll save on submit take the
tags
unless alerted just to make sure things
are working fine so if I sign it bukka
you'll notice quickly that as I
reconnect I get to see all the previous
check-in messages you might recall that
earlier inside of the chat screen file
we specified a message limit of 100 I
just want to use this opportunity to
mention that whenever you connect to a
chat room you have the option to see
retroactive messages or sorry to see all
historical messages for which the on new
message function is called retro
actively that's kind of cool but yeah
you can see here that we have this was
your tax form we type some tax and hit
submits we get to see our taxed but yeah
let's actually send this tax to check it
now before we do that let me quickly
make a few tweaks to our application
States
[Music]
I'm going to create two new state
properties current room and current user
once we successfully connect I want to
save s those states and set the current
user on our state down here you might
recall the earlier I deliberately
created this bank function so then now I
can come here and say set state current
room this will give us wider access to
be current room and current user
properties so that in this case I can
replace the error function hair with a
call to vistas and message I can then
create a send message function the take
some text and say this dot state dot
current user dot send message we can
access current user now you can see we
can also say that the room ID should be
equal to fist or state dog current room
which we now have access to the ID and
the most special five attacks to be
equal to the tag submitted by the form
before this will run we need to come up
here and save this
they'll send message equals visible send
message
define this we're pretty used to doing
this by now let's save that run the
application and see what happens
if I type the text hello and hit submit
you can see for the message shows up
right here what's kind of cause if I
opened up two windows
I'm creates another user called ham we
can see the text I wrote previously and
we can start to talk with each others
like hi I'm ham oh hey
nice to meet you you get the idea the
next thing we'll want to add to our chat
application is typing indicators now
adding typing indicators with chat key
is actually pretty straightforward it
really boils down to two distinct steps
firstly whenever the user starts typing
so if I'm typing in this field we need
to broadcast in a van that tells check
air for a user is typing the second
distinct stab is to essentially
subscribe to that advance so that if for
example I'm typing in this left-hand
window the other clients application
will receive an event to say hey
Booker's typing based on that we can
update our UI to show the user who else
is typing in a particular room or
conversation will integrate with chat
kit in just a second and things will
come together quite swiftly but first we
need to make a small tweak to our send
message form we need a way to be
notified whenever the user types of
character in other words whenever the
input value has changed we can't do that
right now this unchanged prop doesn't
exist so we'll quickly add it by going
to V components folder and the send
message form components and then inside
of this unchanged function we're going
to call this the prop store unchanged
every time the input is updated such but
now if I go back to the chat screen and
back to the render function right here
just to test things of working I can
pass an error function which just writes
to the console updated you'll notice
that we're not actually capturing the
value of the text input simply because
we don't really need it for this and we
can always access it via the on submit
property function anyway but yeah let me
just quickly test this before we go any
further we've seen a few errors today
it's always good to do a little sanity
check if I just pop up from the
developer tools hair and quickly answer
my user name we should see that whenever
I type this updated messages written to
the console that's a great first step
but actually we're not too interested in
just writing since
to the console what we actually want to
do is every time the value is updated
we're going to want to send a typing
advance which will do by a base function
from here we can access the current user
and we call a function called is typing
N and we specify the room ID the user is
typing in which of course we can access
by a bist or state or current room ID
and really bus all we have to do
fundamentally once we have the event
this really boils down to one
significant line of code which is pretty
cool in fact we'll also just catch an
arrow just in case we need to do some
debugging oh and of course as either we
need to come up to V constructor and
bind the function we just defined namely
sense typing events to best so yeah
that's the first significant step and as
you can see it's not even now
significant the next thing we need to do
is to be notified when another user is
typing so we can update our user
interface now it's very possible that
there will be multiple users typing at
the same time and to keep track of this
I'm going to create a new state property
called users who are typing and that's
going to be an array we will update this
state in just a second but first we need
a way to be notified whenever a user
stars or stops typing and the way we do
that a jacket is by specifying a perk
earlier we specified an on new message
event handler essentially this is called
whenever a new message is sent
we can also specify an event handler but
when a user started typing this event
handler receives the user votes
currently started typing we can also
specify an on user stop typing event
handler where again this is the user of
the stopped typing basically so you kind
of test this out real quick we can just
write to the console and let's just
write user
started typing and in this case users
stopped typing if we save this and
quickly run the application in fact let
me quickly change this from user to user
name
[Music]
what we can see is that if I reload the
app and then in one window is sign-in as
Booker and in this other window is
sign-in as much as call it's hashed user
to avoid any kind of confusion as I
start to type as test user you can see
in the left-hand window that in the
console that has two users start typing
I've not stopped typing yet as soon as I
move my hand from the keyboard we get an
Evander says test users stop typing
conversely if I open up the console as
test user and I start typing as myself
as Booker you can see the exact same
event for the other user however we do
not see that event for the current user
because there's no benefit really in
notifying the current user that they are
currently typing of course they know
about typing whether one's typing with a
keyboard the other kind of interesting
thing which you might have noticed is
that there was and is no need to kind of
broadcast in the bank that says hey the
user has stopped typing check I can
figure it out based on how long it's
been since it received an event to say
that a user is typing which is kind of
mean but yeah these events are clearly
hooked up correctly that's awesome it's
now up to us to update our application
state so we can update the user
interface for example in this case when
the user starts typing we essentially
want to do is add their user name to the
users who are typing array which we can
do using the same technique we saw
earlier with the message list when the
user stops typing we're going to want to
remove their username from array what we
should be able to do now is go to the
render function and then just above the
send message form we can save this tour
stay dog users Hewitt's hi pain and if
we serialize that using json stringify
we should be able to just preview this
really quickly in our user interface
before you move on to creating an actual
typing indicator component where we can
render it
in a more proper way
[Music]
I'm so yeah let's test this real quick
just log in his Booker and then his test
yeah we can see the bottom here these
kind of empty parentheses that's being
rendered by react because right now
there are no users type egg as soon as I
start typing his Tash you can see in the
left window that the test is typing I
can start typing you can see the right
wing to a bogus typing same kind of
thing we saw before but now it's in our
UI and what we really want to do is
create a new components called typing
indicator yes we can pass by users who
are typing object down to and render it
properly what we'll do is we'll say if
this the probe start users who are
typing
don't land is equal to zero then we know
that there is no one typing and we can
just return an empty dev otherwise if
this the prop start users who were
typing dot length is equal to one we
know where there's currently one user
typing and we can return a paragraph tag
which is like this table drops but users
who it's high paying will bring out that
first username and then just concatenate
is typing dogs if there are more than
one uses more than one users typing
we'll wants to do is a little bit more
tricky but still very simple will say
this table drops that users who it's
high-paying join and what we'll do is
we'll just join them all those join
function does basically as it takes the
array and it returns back a string with
each element in the array adjoining of
this particular tag so if two users a
typing safe Bob and Jim are typing
you'll say Bob and Jim are typing you
won't really get to experience best in
this screencast will be quite hard to
demonstrate and I'm pretty sure it will
work fine
now if we go back to chat screen ojs and
import typing indicator instead of just
rendering the text we can render the
typing indicator component specify users
who were typing is equal to best those
states don't use to its high pain and
what we should see when we run this
application is a much more proper
formatting for the list of type list of
users who are typing instead of just an
array basically
oh I forgot
under server alright so if I start
typing we can see Hannah's typing if I
start typing is Booker we can see the
book is typing and it's really hard to
demonstrate but if because I can't
really type at the same time with one
keyboard but if they went multiple users
typing we should see the you know Bob
and Jim are typing you know looking at
the application in France servers from a
visual standpoint there's clearly a bit
of work left to do but from the feature
point of view there's only really one
more feature we need to add and that's a
who's online list where we can see a
list of users who've ever joined this
charts as well as their online status
let's add that next you know I'm not
gonna spend too much time on
nitty-gritty styling but I think it
might be useful to create a basic layout
for our application after all what we
really want to see is a sidebar on the
Left hair where we can show a list of
online users and on the right hand side
we can show the chat messages as well as
the charts and message form so before
integrating with Chad care less that
type of basic UI layout what I'm going
to do is create a style property on this
container dev I'm going to set the
display properties of flights will be
using flexbox to set up the layout of
our application within that container
I'm going to create a new kind of sub
container for all of the elements that I
want to be on the right-hand side of the
page above that I'll create another
container this time for the hoos online
list which I'm gonna style very simply
by specifying but I want the width to be
30% of the width of the viewports and
just to kind of give us some visual
indication of what's happening I'm gonna
set a background color here and see what
happens
so if I log in now we can see that we
have this who's online list on the left
and then our chat messages on the right
the first thing that comes to mind is
there obviously this isn't filling the
full height of the
age we can fix that reason really easily
by saying the height property to a
hundred VH that looks good to me one
more small UI layout thing I'll fix is
obviously this text input should
probably be anchored to the bottom and
the way we can do that is by coming down
here wrapping the message list in its
own container the style property and
we're just gonna set the Flex property
to one well clearly that didn't work
that's because I actually need to make
sure that on the container here I set
the displays of flags and ice at the
Flex direction to Colin there we go you
can see there's pushed down to the
bottom obviously you need some padding
and some additional styles we'll talk
about afterwards
well that flex one property I just added
does basically is it tells the browser
to make the message list occupy all the
space it can while still leaving room
for any other elements and because it
has that flex one property it kind of
dominates as you might have guessed by
this point we're going to create a new
component called whose online list Oh
Jas
the idea here is that we're going to
pass down a list of users we're gonna
check if that users property exists if
it does we'll return the list but
otherwise we're going to return the text
loading we can't return nothing and just
render an empty screen that might be
nice to show the loading status and then
what we're going to do if there are some
users is they're going to return a list
inside that list we're going to take
each user and map that user to a list
item
I expect we'll want to make some tweaks
to this component but for now let's head
back to chat screen and import the who's
online this component van down here in
the render function instead of just
rendering the tags who's online list
let's actually render it who's online
list and we're going to pass down the
user's property which is going to be
equal to this dot States the current
room dot users and this is actually
quite a magical property the reason I
say that is that normally in our react
application for example when it comes to
a list of users who are currently typing
we have to manage that state ourselves
we're always adding or removing items
from an array or an object when it comes
to managing users but no need to manage
that state ourselves because the chat
client SDK
does that for us this users property is
always up to date it always reflects the
up to dates states of your chats
application so whenever someone gets
joins they get added to this property if
their online status changes whether they
go offline or come back online
it's completely reflected by this
property which means that when it comes
to updating our user interface what we
really have to do you know because
obviously when someone comes online or
goes offline we want to update our user
interface and we can use hooks like we
did for the typing events so we can say
when the user comes online
rather than updating any kind of state
all we really have to do is call vest of
force updates and what that's going to
do in turn the same for when a user went
offline or whenever a user joined for
that matter whenever any of these events
happen we're going to call force updates
and what that really translates to in
react speak is call this render function
again and when this render function gets
called again the users property gets
evaluated again and that should reflect
the state of our application in fact one
thing and like I said we probably we're
going to end up tweaking that and who's
online list one thing we can do is we
can come back down here where we
returned the list item of the user name
and in parentheses we can render the
user the presence those states which is
either going to be online or offline we
just made a lot of changes at once so
we'll see what happens when we bring the
application
yeah I kind of expected after ranked
that much code I probably made a typo
which is the quite easy quite an easy
fix if I go to the chat screen and I
think I just need to add honors at the
end of each of these statements but once
that's up and running successfully
oops and again I need to call super
always always always forget to do that
actually this component doesn't even
have a constructor it's because I missed
hyper component here I think cool let's
see what happens if I log in and we see
about loading text once we connected and
now this is cool we see a list of all
the users who've ever joined this room
like Robby's tutorial I connected his
hand and his test then I stashed user if
I open it never window real quick now
watch this take a look at test user
right here currently test users offline
but soon as I join
that offline tags changes the online
which is super cool
the other cool thing is that if I head
back here basically closing the chat up
pay attention to test users online
status boom test user goes offline and
one more thing I want to test is that if
I create a new user and I join the room
we should see about new user
yes gets added to the list of online
users and that pretty much integrates
with the same kind of system you know if
we close the tab that user pays offline
wicked and that looks awesome to me I'm
gonna pause the screencast and I'm gonna
take a bit of time off-camera making
this chat application look a bit better
but all the basic functionality is there
which I'm really excited about alright I
made some updates if I run the
application and log back in
you can see it looks a lot better now
trust me
you might think it would've been nice to
see me add the style step by step but it
was fiddly a bit boring and really about
slide the scope of this tutorial
besides the complete code zone gets up
where you can browser download it
adapter
maybe even use it as the foundation to
your next up
check it is a tool I'm helping to build
a pusher I'm really excited about it if
you think you can save you time and help
you build a better product faster but
seem and I would love to help you are
very very welcome to join our slack
channel where you can reach the team and
I'd directly with your questions
there'll be a link in the description as
well and all of our documentation pages
we have a chat if you want to pop up
there of course I would love to hear
your thoughts about this video or indeed
chuck in the comment section as well
thank you so much for watching I really
hope you found it interesting
I've been likes book a good bye